لا يجب ان يخشى الكوميديون واصحاب النكته
على انفسهم من الذكاء الاصطناعي على ما
يبدو فبصراحه يبدو انه روح الفكاهه لدى
الذكاء الاصطناعي ليست موجوده او سميجه
جدا
الموصوفه بانها الاكثر تقدما في العالم
هذا الروبوت فشل عند محاوله
القاء نكته حيث افتقد في هذه النقطه الى
اي جانب مضحك فيها
ما بيقد
روا الذكاء الاصطناعي ما بيقدر يستبدلنا
تعابير
وجه
الناظر لم تمنحها امكانيه ان تكون ذات
نكته مضحكه حيث اجابت على سؤال حول القاء
نكته بطريقه غريبه قال في النكته
سمع روبوت
بذكاء اصطناعي يمكنه حل اي مشكله
قالت انها احدثت او احدث نكته وصلتها فيما
بدا صوتها يخفت وهي تلقي هذه النكته
المفترضه اذا متاكده
يعني اكيد بالاحساس غير موجود الى الان
عند الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن اذا ما تمكن من
ان يكون هذا الاحساس موجود في الذكاء
الاصطناعي خلص علينا السلام لانه لغايه
الان يعني في شغلات في بعض الم
ناحي من الذكاء الاصطناعي يستبدلنا فيها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات